[Music]
the secret to start learning a language
and keep learning it is simple connect
with it emotionally every day when I sit
down and I learn I remind myself of why
I am learning
reminding myself of the reasons why is
the most important thing you can do to
keep going I use a simple visualization
technique to emotionally connect with a
language which I call C C stands for
state your state of mind has a huge
impact on how you learn and how you see
yourself in the now and in the future he
stands for emotion there is no learning
no plan and no life without emotion to
make things strong and solid and
emotions to whatever you do he stands
for I in this case the eye of your mind
with this eye you can see things that
your physical eyes still cannot see see
beyond to make your future real make
your future a reality I'm in Budapest
I'm standing on one side of the marker
bridge on the one side of the river in
pest
I see the massive anger in Parliament in
all its illuminated glory and on the
outer side I see the green hills of
Bhutan now cloaked in the darkness of
night all at once I'm overcome with a
wave of nostalgia for a moment that
seems like an eternity and caught
between the past and the future and that
reminds me of when I was here for the
first time some 10 years ago and then my
friend edit comes she smiles at me we
decide to head over to a restaurant we
order on gear and food we talk about
everything about Hungary Budapest and
guarantee the year and wine our history
about the differences between Hungary
and the night goes on
[Music]
you